مرحبا نبدا كواليس هذا الاسبوع مع الفنان
محمد عساف واللي اطلق اغنيته الجديده بنت
الجده مؤخرا واللي حضرتك كاميرا كواليس عن
الاغنيه وعن اسباب قله انتاجو الفتره
الماضيه ومشاريعه الفنيه خلال الفتره
القادمه
رؤيه الشاعر
كانت اختيار موضوع انه بالتحديد انه بنجد
رغم انه الاغنيه ما فيش فيها هاي الكلمه
انه بنت جده بالتحديد هي اغنيه غزليه اكثر
تتغزل بنجده خلينا نحكي ولكن انه كلمه بنت
جده يعني خذوني يا عرب عند حبيبي ساكن
بجده
اكثر البحث دائما
الفنان او خليني احكي انا بشكل خاص
لدي استراتيجيه معينه في اختيار الاغاني
يعني بيجيني بشكل يومي اغاني من ملحنين
وكتاب وموزعين كثير كثير يعني لو اسمعك
على التليفون شو بيجيني اغاني بشكل كبير
جدا لكن اليوم عيار الاختيار هو اصبح صعب
جدا في ظل يعني انت بتشوف كميه الاغاني
اللي بنسمعها في كل عالمنا العربي بشكل
عام وفي الخليج يمكن كمان بشكل خاص اصبح
من الصعب انه انت تتنبا بنجاح اغنيه
يا عرب عنده حبيبي
ساكن بجده انا
مشتاق لجدا بموت احتاج
لبده افلام كثيره قادمه خلال الفتره
الجايه ينتظرها عشاق السينما بحماس كبيره
من بين هذه الافلام فيلم الشماريخ للمخرج
عمرو سلامه واللي يلعب بطولته اسر ياسين
وامينه خليل وتدور احداثه في اطار من
الحركه والتشويق انا خلاص قربت اخلص فيلم
جديد اسمه شماريخ الفيلم بطوله اسيا ياسين
وامينه خليل وناس تانيه كتير جدا
والفيلم انتاج شركه سينما هو تاليفي
اخراجي
وان شاء الله يطرح في السينمات في خلال
الصيف او العيد الكبير في مصر والوطن
العربي وان شاء الله يا رب
هنعرف في الفيلم بقى يعني الفيلم بيحكي
قصه معينه قصه اكشن فيها رومانسيه
وكوميديا بس هو وفي دراما وهو فيلم برضه
عندي من زمان جدا جدا يمكن اول مره كتبته
كانت سنه 2007 فاحنا بنتكلم من حوالي 15
سنه
وقعد يتطور كتير قوي على مدار السنين دي
سحب فيه المعزيرو لمحمد رمضان ونيل الكريم
من سباق عيد الاضحى السينمائي حيث اكدت
الشركه المنتجه الامر في بيان رسمي لافته
لانه سببه هو الضيق الوقت حيث لا زال
التصوير ام مستمر بينما تبقى كل عمليات مع
بعض الانتاج واللي صعب الانتهاء منها قبل
العيد لكن مصادر كواليس اكدت انه الاسباب
مختلفه تماما وانه فشل هارلي على الشباك
السعودي كان سبب رئيس الاتحاد هذا القرار
حيث راى الجميع انه نزول الفيلم في
المنافسه امام نجوم صف اول كان يدي منى
زكي وكريم عبد العزيز واحمد السقا ليس من
مصلحه الفيلم وان محمد رمضان يجب ان يغيب
عن الشباك قليلا
نتوقف الان مع عدد من الفنانين الشباب
السعوديين واللي التقينا فيهم في مهرجان
الافلام الاوروبيه مؤخرا في الرياض وعرفنا
شويه اراء مناح قاعدين نلتقي بثقافه
مختلفه ثقافه جديده علينا
وقاعد قاعد احنا وياهم
نتمها في نفس الفكره نشوف افلام جديده
علينا من ثقافه مختلفه عنا خصوص الافلام
الاوروبيه هي احد افضل الافلام اللي انا
احبها فانا مبسوط انه صار عندنا هالشيء
ومبسوط انه يصير هاللقاءات بين كل
هالثقافات السينمائيه بيننا وبين قاره
اوروبا طبعا مهم انه نتفرج على افلامهم
ونتعرف عليها وحابه كمان تواجدي بها
المهرجان كثير اليوم احنا موجودين في مكان
سعيدين في غايه السعاده واللي قاعد يحصل
اليوم يعني باي حال من الاحوال ما يتجزا
عن النهضه وعن التحرك للامام اللي قاعد
يحصل في كل المجالات وجود مثل هذه
المهرجانات اكيد انها بتفتح افاق كبيره في
السعوديه
والصناع السينما والصناع الافلام في
السعوديه عام انه يكون في تبادل خبرات
اولا حنا ممكن الافلام اللي بتعرض هنا ما
هو مو بسهوله نشوفها في سواء في السينما
السعوديه او حتى في المنصات فهذه فرصه
حلوه ان احنا نشوفها زائد انه نلتقي في
الصناع نفسهم حنشوف فيلم
مرشح للاوسكار ويهمنا انه احنا نطلع برضو
على الثقافات الاوروبيه بما انه اصلا
المهرجان اسمه المهرجان الافلام الاوروبيه
في السعوديه اليوم الاجتماع هذا اجتماع
مختلف اللي هو مهرجانات الافلام الاوروبي
في
هذه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات